I don't believe in going deep into your
inner self
[Music]
so the notion of a game has as an
assumption that there are set and
replicable rules or laws to the game
yeah and equally that there is a
predictable endpoint within a narrow
range of possibilities
both of those preconditions rely on the
perception of radical human control
replicable rules and a fixed Terminus a
fixed endpoint within a narrow
constraint of options so I'd like to
share with you a 60-second walk into
another view of how life's built 60
seconds please thank you I'm going to
invite you to clear out your inner space
with three breaths have the option to
close your eyes and walk you if you wish
an invitation through a 60-second
thought visualization okay
I invite you to close your eyes I invite
you to take three breaths one
two
three
I invite you to think of a time where
you wanted something so badly in the
game of life that you researched it you
strategized you had your tactics a plus
b plus C that red door was yours that
job that University him heard them to
say yes to live there that red door was
yours a b c you'd done it right
you go for the handle and it's stuck and
it seems untenable in this game of life
99 certainty because you had done a plus
b plus c
you might kick the door you might be
shocked you might even be depressed
but only because the red door was stuck
you had no choice you turned 40 80 110
degrees and there
was a wide open shining yellow door
you may have said that yellow doors
don't exist you've never thought of
yellow doors on the other side is
someone more right for you is a job that
made you feel alive is a mentor
who brought you in a whole new Direction
it was not what you had wanted it was
better
than what you had wanted
and as you sit back and you look at that
stuck Red Door The Hairpin turn that
brought you to the wide open yellow door
that has everything to do with who you
are and where you are today
was anyone
standing there at The Hairpin turn a
parent a grandparent someone you met for
two minutes at the tea or coffee shop
someone on the bus
a trail angel
who pointed you to the yellow door
and finally now as you sit back stuck
Red Door hairpin turned Trail Angel
pointing you to the yellow door
how really are the most important parts
of our Lives found is it narrowly
through strategy and tactics or do those
certainly have their place in
preparation
but are the most finest directive parts
of our lives
some type of dialogue not with walking
in inert stage
but in a dynamic dialogue with a dynamic
guiding force in and through all life
is it possible you've been on a quest a
spiritual path all along
sitting that way back
stuck Red Door hairpin turned Trail
Angel wide open yellow door wearing your
road of life
is the force is the source Universe God
Hashem Allah that which is in us through
us and around us is this force in the
trail Angel ending you hearing the trail
Angel is the force in the open yellow
door
and even the stuck Red Door
so life has times for strategy
and preparation but life perhaps in your
own path is alive and has a force of its
own
thank you very much
I don't believe in going deep into your
inner self sorry to be brutal if you go
deep into it you find deep heat the
right way monstrous Santa this and so on
I believe that the only way to
overcome yourself is to
identify with your mask just to conclude
things they don't drag on my favorite
movie here Rossellini you should see it
you can get it on YouTube from 1960 I
think with Victoria the thika with Oreo
General Della
uh uh the thika plays a poor guy who is
caught it's still occupied Italy caught
by the Nazis and since he looks exactly
like General Della rovere a big name of
resistance they tell him we killed de la
rovere but resistance that we have
imprisoned don't know this so go there
pretend that you are General Bella
rovere and people will confide in you
and you will tell us that you can guess
what is the ending he identified so much
to his role that he is ready to die he
doesn't say anything at his shot
publicly as general Della Rover in this
sense I am for good alienation who cares
about his real self a poor beggar and so
on in this complete identification with
another you can find Freedom but also
horror did you see with Jim Carrey his
best film I think did you see the mask
where he is completely free but
nightmare comes out this complete
freedom to do what you want he
experiences it as a as a nightmare so in
this more precise sense I think that uh
that first there is something liberating
in games and cliches can you imagine how
horrible life would have been if you
were to tell just the truth sincerely
without hypocrisy there is no life
without hypocrisy hypocrisy gives me and
it works that's the game I will conclude
don't don't be afraid I know I'm
definitely taking YouTube history French
spirit I see it yeah no uh uh look I
meet you let's say or you on the street
and I say I'm so glad to meet you what
is in my mind as it's probably the case
because I'm an evil guy why didn't
I note you one minute earlier to go to
the other side of the road and we both
know it but nonetheless although we know
that this is mostly a hypocritical empty
Forum it works performatively as a sign
of kindness this is for me a good
alienation don't I I hate people who
open themselves up and I don't want to
hear them I mean all the dirty we need
hypocrisy
um
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas